[موسيقى]
الموت مثل الأغنية
يحدث بمرور الوقت ، وهناك
بداية له ، وهناك
ذروة ثم هناك نهاية
أعتقد أن لديها إمكانية
تحسين حياتنا
بدلاً من أخذ شيء بعيدًا
عنها ،
اسمي كيت مونجر أنا
مؤسس جوقة العتبة
التي نغنيها بجانب أسرة الأشخاص
الذين يحتضرون ، لقد
بدأت أول جوقة في مارس
2000 بعد
ستة أشهر بعد ذلك بجوقتين أخريين
واليوم هناك 150 كورالًا حول
العالم
[موسيقى]
في عام 1990 قضيت فترة ما بعد الظهر
آخذ  اعتني بصديق كان
يحتضر بسبب الإيدز
وكان في غيبوبة ومضطرب
ولم أكن أعرف
ماذا أفعل فبدأت
الغناء له بشكل غريزي
وبدأ يهدأ وبدأت أهدأ ،
علمت أنني
اكتشفت شيئًا قديمًا
وهذا  كنت أرغب في
إعادة الأغاني التي نحضرها إلى السرير وهي في الغالب أغانٍ كتبناها ،
إنها قصيرة ، فهي تغني بهدوء شديد
، وتوفر كلمات الأغاني الراحة
التي توفر الصفاء ، فهي توفر
البساطة والسهولة
[موسيقى]
سنطرق الباب ونحاول التسلل
إلى الغرفة حيث يموت الشخص
بلطف مثل الفراشة التي أتينا
للغناء من أجلك
[موسيقى]
غالبًا ما نرى أنفاسك
تهدئ أحيانًا  ترى نقرًا على إصبع القدم أو تحريك
إصبع بابتسامة ، وبعد ذلك عندما ننتهي من
الخروج بهدوء في كثير من الأحيان ،
سنترك الغناء
[موسيقى] يقول
العديد من الأشخاص الذين غنينا لهم أن
آلامهم قد تلاشت.  هذه
معجزة بالنسبة لي
[موسيقى]
لك